Marcela
good evening rather good morning ladies
and gentlemen and welcome to the first
press conference after the first day of
the June European Council I first invite
the President of the European Council
Donald Tusk to take the floor Lisa thank
you Kevin let me start on nominations
tonight we have reached the following
outcome so if the European Council had a
full discussion of nominations taking
into account my consultations and
statements made within the European
Parliament there was no majority on any
candidate the European Council agreed
that the needs to be a package
reflecting the diversity of the you will
meet again on the 30th of June in the
meantime I will continue consultations
including with the European Parliament
beyond nominations the European Council
covered a number of issues including the
long term your budget adopting the
strategic agenda and confirming the
rollover of economic sanctions against
Russia for another six months due to the
non implementation of the Minsk
agreement we also discussed how to
ensure a climate neutral EU in line with
the Paris agreement a vast majority of
member states has committed to climate
neutrality by 2050 but reaching
unanimity was not possible today however
we have good reason to believe that this
may change as no country ruled out the
possibility of a positive decision in
the coming months last but not least
president Navi Araz updated us on the
situation of the coast of Cyprus the
European Council stands ready to respond
appropriately and in full solidarity
with Cyprus the Commission and external
Action Service have been instructed to
event options of measures thank you
thank you and now president Juncker of
the European Commission I don't think
that it is a wise idea to have a press
conference at two o'clock in the morning
you agree we had an important meeting
mainly as far as the cyprus turkey
question is concerned we are in full
solidarity with cyprus what turkey is
doing in the territorial waters of
cyprus is totally unacceptable the
Commission has been charged to propose
measures to be taken as soon as possible
when it comes to this conflict and will
do so and this will not be soft measures
April arrest is an area now sit for the
rest I have nothing to add to what
you've just heard from president tusk I
noted with some pleasure satisfaction
amusement happiness even that it appears
are not that easy to replace
Donald has had all sorts of
consultations he'll have more the next
meeting will be on the 30th of June but
we will also be on all soccer for the
g20 in the meantime and we'll have
opportunities to discuss follow up I
remain of the view of that the Spitz in
candidate and process has not reached
its a term yet you because I'm tired and
for that reason well so only take a few
questions I think Jim you were the first
thank you thank you Jim Bronstein from
the Financial Times
why do you expect that it will be any
easier to get a deal on a package of top
jobs on the 30th of June than it is
today on well now the 21st of June thank
you I don't accept I don't accept
expect that but it has to be done
okay good night
good morning hello with your active
after today's discussions have you
narrowed down the list of candidates and
for example have you excluded the
possibility that monthly whoever could
be the candidate for the European
Commission and if that is the case the
EPP will have the right to put forward
another alternative or they people will
have exclusively the right to appoint
the candidate for the other candidate
they can do for their Commission I
mentioned we need more time to discuss
the whole landscape and the Deaf if I
will go back to this issue at the end of
June and today is too early to prejudge
names and and in the post I was saying
during the meeting that the day you have
appointed president a commission you
have to forget from which party you are
coming if you are leading the Commission
in a partisan way it will be a total
failure so when you are asking what the
EPP will do ask the president of the EPP
not me one final question you actually
as well this one but you are the vice
president DPP yes but I didn't know it
until today the statute foresees that
you and myself we have as presidents I'm
not feeling it as the vice president Li
PB this workers
question to president - that's nice
I'm giving you the floor you asked in
dollars okay
learn something for me I think of it as
president tusk is in the Proceedings is
your name has your name being added to
the list of names for presidency of the
Commission no fortunately not thank you
this concludes the press conference
[Laughter]